last night it was my great privilege to
speak with Robert mikans and Elizabeth
Alvarado whose fifteen-year-old daughter
Anissa Mickens was murdered by ms-13
gang members they were guests as I said
at a president Trump at Tuesday's State
of the Union address as were my next
guests
Evelyn Rodriguez and Freddy Cuevas they
are the parents of Kayla Cuevas a 16
year old who was also killed by ms-13
gang members and both of you I want to
say I know it's very difficult to come
out and talk about this subject because
it makes you think of what happened to
your daughter just two years ago not
even two years ago but we really
appreciate your testimony and your
witness to what what is the truth so
thank you so much thank you for having
me Evelyn
I'd like to start with you you've heard
the sentiment expressed time and again
that the president Trump is making too
much of this ms-13 issue that it's being
used for just political purposes and
people people didn't even know about
ms-13 unless it was for Fox News kind of
dismissing it what's your reaction to
that you know it's a situation that it's
pretty much all over and we need to find
a solution in order to take care of this
it is a serious problem and I just don't
want another family to go through the
pain that we've been enduring every day
since this happened Freddie
for our viewers who don't know the
brutality of ms-13 tell us what happened
to Kayla
unfortunately that sad day Kayla was
announced by Nisa and you know her best
friend you know to go into into
seeing a friend and what not so they
went over to see a friend so they can
tackle whatever situations they had
which was very minor and they went over
there they made the friendship they made
the peace on the way back that's when I
think the situation good situation
occurred things went wrong they was
already in the parking lot and there was
you know hanging out there in the
parking lot whatnot and unfortunately
the my daughter and Misa on that
specific day happened to be crossing the
boundaries of Loretto Park so once they
cross the Loretto Park and being then
parked in the red apart they happen to
come across the controversy well the the
motto of ms-13 is kill rape and control
and Evelyn I have a daughter who's 12
and a half years old and my heart breaks
for you two to have read what they did
to her but they beat both girls with a
baseball bat and police who found them
said they had not ever seen such
brutality
they'd never may seen a lot in Long
Island never seen anything like it
you were there at the State of the Union
and there are a lot of people who stood
and applauded for your courage and for
your daughter there are a lot of people
who sat on their hands scowling what do
you say to them tonight those who would
not stand to honor your daughter you
know everybody has their opinions I just
want to thank for those who stood up and
believed in what we're trying to do you
know I I don't know what they were
thinking I know as a parent I'm feeling
the loss of my daughter
I feel it every day
there's not a day a second that I don't
think about my daughter and they just
don't understand the pain of a parent
losing their child to this gang violence
and I hope they never will
it's something that you don't think
about you know our kids should be
burying us when we're ready to go not
the parents burying their kids their
lives are ahead of them you know I just
want the government to really think
about the choices and the solutions and
the plans that they have in order to
take care of this problem it's a serious
problem they need to really consider it
I know there's other issues here in the
US but this is one issue that that they
need to tackle on well I think there's a
there's a lot of empathy expressed on a
daily basis for people who are in the
country illegally who fear deportation
and I'm sure you know that's a
legitimate fear what we want to do on
this show is showcase those who are
forgotten and until President Trump came
along I think they were largely ignored
or invisible victims but we think the
empathy should should go to American
citizens who are brutally hurt and
harmed and killed by people who should
never have been in this country in the
first place and that's what we're gonna
do every night and we just salute you
for coming on and I know how hard it is
you're not a political person but I
think we need solutions that I just
ensure this to be none of this happens
again I'm sorry this can't you have made
sure no absolutely not absolutely not
you know I just want the resources and
the programs and the funding to arm to
come into our community and the schools
and like I said this is not just
happening here in Suffolk County it's
happening all over 40 states there are
10,000 members of ms-13 all across the
United States
Evelyn Freddie I really appreciate your
time thank you for being with us tonight
thank you thank you for having us as
well